é um pouco de loucura que está dentro de
mim vou mostrar para as criaturas que a
vida é sempre assim não tem muita
cultura para seguir esses caminhos
mas minhas aventuras eu sei que não
estou sozinho eu não sei para onde vou
ninguém sabe de onde vim mas se deus me
convidou
vão ficar até o fim fg olímpicas ou
contadora de histórias há muito tempo
gostava de olhar no olho das pessoas e
quando cada vez que eu contava uma
história
gostava de ouvir o que as pessoas
contavam
decidi então fazer pedagogia era algo
que já estava em mim gostava muito de
ser professora imaginava que era ser
professora
ser professor é ser livre achava que ser
professor podia fazer o que quisesse na
sala de aula
gostava de olhar o olho das crianças
brilharem
a cada história lembro até hoje de um
professor de biologia que me chamou num
canto da sala e disse não acredito que
vai fazer pedagogia
já vi o professor ser rico saí de lá
meio abalada pensando que ele fazia ali
na verdade eu nunca quis ser rica eu
queria ser feliz
em contrapartida houve a minha mãe dizer
professor é profissão do futuro e que eu
não pensasse o que não daria certo muito
bem eu não tinha muita experiência
comecei a trabalhar numa biblioteca
naquela biblioteca eu sabia que todos lá
mas sabiam importância de ler mas os
alunos não liam percebia que o pai a mãe
a mídia escola mostravam que ele era
importante mas eles não liam a união
ainda me motivava
lembro me até hoje também da minha
primeira aula de pedagogia
quando a minha professora perguntou qual
o motivo da escolha daqueles das alunas
das 30 perder 30 alunos que tinham
passado em pedagogia somente cinco
queriam ser professora
as outras não tinham passado em medicina
arquitetura e ainda estavam lá toda a
lista umas futuras pedagogas né
nesta biblioteca que eu comecei a
trabalhar eu queria mudar
percebi que as bibliotecas ficavam
sempre lugares de difícil acesso
mesmo que eu contasse as histórias às
crianças ainda não estava motivada e
algo ainda não me motivava também
comecei um trabalho voluntário nas
bibliotecas e que não tinham contadores
de histórias contava histórias às
bibliotecas ficavam no fundo da escola
ou no último andar
os livros eram todos organizados da
mesma forma as crianças não viam as
capas nem sabiam que livros tinham ali
os livros eram também de difícil acesso
as crianças não tinham a prática de
pegar o livro eu continuei contando
histórias eu queria ver a poesia no
olhar de cada criança eu era muito nova
não tinha o hábito de preparar a aula
certa vez chegou uma turma de 1º ano
para que eu contasse uma história na
época 1ª série crianças sentaram todas
lindas queridinhos e eu apavorada que eu
vou fazer agora peguei as bibliotecárias
receber um pacote de livros para
analisar
peguei o primeiro livro que houve um
escritor super bem conceituado olhei vai
ser essa história nem comecei as
crianças sentadas a história era de um
super herói
ele era uma mesma gini ou super herói
ele era maravilhoso cheiro gostoso
grande bonito rápido tudo que esse
super-herói fazia era perfeito
certa vez um super herói estava na sua
casa deitado quando ouviu e as crianças
americanas
quando senti um cheiro de fumaça o
super-herói saiu correndo viu uma porta
e atravessou a porta a porta estava
escrito atenção em caso de incêndio não
entre como super herói não sabia ler nem
escrever
morreu queimado a minha sorte que o olho
vai bem mais rápido do que a boca
botei o livro para trás e disse o super
herói por ser tão boa pagou só viveu
feliz para sempre
é claro que naquele momento resolvi ser
contadora de histórias
senti muito medo poderia ter desistido
ali mas não eu queria muito ser
contadora de histórias há um detalhe a
última página daquele livro eram as
cinzas do super herói no decorrer da
minha caminhada
fui convidada pelo hospital santo
antônio para dar uma oficina de
contadores de histórias que hoje faz
parte da ong doutores vizinhas onde atuo
como fazedora de histórias
levamos alegria e encantamento aos
hospitais
usamos adereço sim mas o nosso objeto
maior é o riso a alegria ea vontade de
contar histórias
certa vez vestida de bruxa todos me
chamam de bruxa ano
vestida toda de bruxa chamávamos as
crianças pra sair e menino quando me viu
e começou a chorar
quanto mais aquele menino chorava mas eu
tirava a roupa para ele se acalmar
nem sempre pavor na star no hospital e
ver uma bruxa se desmanchando
percebemos que ao entrar no hospital
algo mágico acontece por no meio das
lágrimas de dor e sofrimento vem a
alegria vem um sorriso esse trabalho na
ong doutor zhivago tem enriquecido não
só como profissional mas como pessoa
porque eu percebo que tanto na sala de
aula quanto no hospital
as coisas podem acontecer eu percebo que
a inovação não está em fazer algo
mirabolante
a inovação está aqui na paixão no na
alegria de ver o outro sorrir
as histórias o riso tem o poder de fazer
com que as crianças nunca deixem de
sonhar acreditar imaginar aonde do ator
zinhos me mostra a importância de fazer
com que cada criança só escutar pois
assim iremos tornar esses adultos nossas
crianças em adultos menos racionais no
rio nos duros e tão imediata quanto são
torne gigante cada vez que o hospital
sei que todos os voluntários também no
sentindo assim superou mas não morre
queimado contar histórias no hospital é
algo que vai além do esperado
me sinto presenteado ao sair de cada
quarto
os doutores vizinhos levam a contação de
histórias para as crianças
hospitalizadas por acreditar que somente
elas são capazes de transformar de fazer
uma verdadeira transformação através das
histórias sim podemos diagnosticar
sintomas de humor e de transformá los em
alegrias contar histórias no hospital é
poder fazer as crianças sorrirem larga
gargalhar um situações vividas pelas
personagens é através delas e através
dessas histórias descobrir outros
lugares
ao contar histórias no hospital nos
perguntamos o que realmente importa para
aquelas crianças que estão ali chegamos
à conclusão que para elas a estar no
hospital ênfase à importância à vida é
apenas uma parte do caminho
chego à conclusão que todas aquelas
crianças agem com naturalidade e o que
importa para a ong doutor zhivago sé que
cada paciente ria shores emocione
gricchi de muitas gargalhadas porque as
emoções são para serem sentidas
é preciso de exemplos não de discursos
sempre trabalhamos com a idéia os
motorzinhos não chegam lá simplesmente
assim eles passam por um processo super
rigoroso pensar em alguém que entra no
hospital pra contar uma história recente
brigou em casa
poesia brincar com palavras como se
brinca com gola pagar fiança
só que bola pra pagar piano de tanto
brincar se gasto
as palavras não quanto mais se brincam
com elas - novas ficam soma água do rio
que agora sempre 9
como cada dia que é sempre um novo dia
de brincar de poesia ninguém a gostar de
ouvir um poema assim né
nem a criança que está no hospital
nenhum aluno
sala de aula é preciso que a gente sinta
as palavras é preciso que o contador se
emocione 5 que está falando
vou tentar fazer diferente poesia
brincar com palavras como se brinca com
bola pra pagar e peão só que bola pra
pagar e peão de tanto brincar se gasto
as palavras não quanto mais se brinca
com elas mas novelas ficam como água do
rio que água sempre nova como cada dia
que é sempre um novo dia então vamos
brincar de poesia tem uma diferença né
é preciso fazer com que as crianças
sejam verdadeiras nos seus gestos nas
suas ações
o que importa para os voluntários não é
que eles passam ridículo ocupação feio o
que importa realmente é que nós agimos
com naturalidade a naturalidade de uma
criança a imaginação
deve ser uma amiga verdadeira real e até
mesmo em real o que importa realmente é
que eles não hajam cumprir conceito
afinal está no hospital ou não é ser
diferente e ser diferente não é mais nem
menos
é apenas ser diferente fernando pessoa
diz que a única maneira de ter sensações
novas é construir de uma alma nova
baldado esforço teu se querem sentir
outras coisas sem sentir isso de outra
maneira e sentires de outra maneira sem
mudares de alma porque as coisas são
como nós sentimos a quanto tempo sabe
isto isso sem saberes e o único modo de
haver coisas novas de sentir coisas
novas é haver novidade nos sentidos muda
de alma como descobre o mtur
desde que nascemos até que morremos
mudamos de alma lentamente como do corpo
arranjar meios de tornar rápido essa
mudança como certas doenças ou certas
convalescença
obviamente o corpo se nos muda sentir as
palavras é isso é fazer com que as
crianças vivam sintam se emocione
todos nós somos aprendizes
além que capri um pequeno infante sadio
e brincante a china 10 e asas nos pés
com chumbo doc é aplique ploc olhar
verde caio parecia um raio para gerir na
peão ou menina
seu corpo moreno devia correndo pulava
no escuro não importa que muro só tava
de anjo melhor que marmanjo e dava um
mergulho sem fazer barulho em bola de
meia jogando de meia direita ou de pouco
passava da conta que tanto driblar a
nasa era mar
a mazda leonora menina de cor amazonas
criadas da renda as escadas amarras
golias da rua dias amadas as primas com
beijos e rimas amarras tias de peles
macias amazonas artistas da cena e
revistas amava a mulher a mais não poder
por isso fazia seu grande poesia e
achava bonita a palavra escrita por isso
ele sofria de melancolia sonhando um
poeta que quem sabe um dia poderia ser
poeta aprendiz de vinicius de moraes e
nunca fez
ser professor é isso e nunca esqueça que
esse faz de conta realmente acontece
obrigado